there are degrees of Leverage and this
is wholeheartedly taken from nval I
remember as the four C's collaboration
Capital code and content those are the
four C's of Leverage right now we make
this podcast and we put x amount of
effort in but we get unlimited upside on
it millions of people can see it or one
person can see it but we get more for
what we put in the better and better we
get at this code you can write an app
one time and then unlimited amount of
people can use the code or use the app
collaboration is I say okay I will now
teach 20 guys to sell and I will get 10
times the output that I had if I were
selling and so I might not take any
sales calls but make more sales than
anybody else does because I have more
leverage